now the US president Donald Trump is
planning to extend his controversial
travel ban to more countries he made
that announcement just a short time ago
as he was leaving the World Economic
Forum in Davos and heading back to
Washington DC where his impeachment
trial is starting we have to be safe our
country has to be safe you see what's
going on in the world our country has to
be safe so we have a very strong travel
ban and we'll be adding a few countries
to it let's bring in our White House
correspondent Kimberly halqa to first
discuss what he had to say on the travel
ban was this expected at all we did hear
this was in the works but the White
House well they said they were looking
at adding countries would not specify
which ones we now know Belarus Burma
Nigeria Tanzania Eritrea Kyrgyzstan and
Sudan now this is a pretty controversial
policy it was certainly controversial
when it was first implemented because
many thought that it equated to a Muslim
ban given some of the president's
statements about Muslims out on the
campaign trail the fact that it applied
to Muslim majority countries in fact it
was even challenged in the US Supreme
Court ultimately a five-to-four decision
back in 2018 that this could be upheld
that Iran Libya Syria Somalia and Yemen
would still have this ban applied to
them the argument that the Trump
administration has made all along is
this is not about ethnicity this is not
about nationality or even religion that
this is about security protocol and that
these particular countries now with
these news when added are simply not
complying with the strict protocols of
the United States when it comes to
biometrics counterterrorism basic
security requirements in fact there were
two countries that were initially on the
original list Iraq and Chad they stepped
up their game if you will when it comes
to security we're removed from the list
and the White House is telling al
Jazeera that that is this case for these
new countries that have been added if
they fall into compliance with US
security requirements they will be able
to be removed from that list all right
and Kimberly he certainly had a lot to
say on the impeachment trial currently
underway in Washington he's heading back
to wash
just talked us through some of the
highlights there yeah it was a bit of a
shift in mood the president had been at
Davos really quite upbeat as he mingled
with the world's elites but he seems to
be shifting back into attack mode now
knowing that that Senate trials set to
begin again at 18:00 GMT and that he
will be back in the United States almost
face to face with his critics and he
seems to be attacking them head-on in
fact the president not only once again
maintaining that he would like to have
witnesses in this trial as Democrats
have been pushing for but he says he
can't because of national security and
he also use some pretty strong language
the president using word I've never
heard a president used before calling
Democrats his his opposition in all of
this sleaze bags which is certainly very
shocking language still the president
maintains that he's committed no
wrongdoing and this is all just an
agenda to remove him from office
something he says has been in the works
tried to keep him out of the political
realm from the day he announced his
candidacy he's still fighting back take
a listen it's a total hoax it's a
disgrace they talked about their
tremendous case and it's all done their
tremendous case they had no case it's
all a hoax it's a con job like Jeff he's
a corrupt politician the president is
also continuing to distance himself from
a man who has testified in least in
television interviews a man by the name
of left Parnas that he was a part of the
president's parallel diplomacy towards
Ukraine the president distancing himself
from harness saying in fact he was just
a group he who showed up at fundraisers
in the midst of all of this the
president also believes that fighting
back against this impeachment he
believes is something very important
that the history will look on him kindly
in fact he said in his press conference
there in Davos I'm not enjoying it but I
think it's the greatest thing I've ever
done for our country so it's certainly
his view I'm not sure it's shared by
everyone in the United States
all right Kimberly we'll be speaking to
you throughout the day for the time
being thank you so as we mentioned the
US Senate has now agreed on the rules
for that impeachment trial of Donald
Trump following nearly 13 hours
debates she Albert ANSI reports on a
long Opening Day that stretched well
into the night our founders trusted the
Senate to rise above short-term passions
at the last moment Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell altered his
proposed rules for the impeachment trial
gone was the possibility that the
evidence connected during the various
House inquiries might not be entered
into evidence in the Senate trial and
the Democratic Party House managers and
White House lawyers would now have three
days and not two to make their opening
statements that left the issue of
witnesses and documents House Democrats
argue that they were withheld in the
course of their inquiries into whether
Donald Trump was withholding
congressionally mandated military aid
for Ukraine in return for an
investigation into former Vice President
Joe Biden and that these must be
produced in the Senate trial so leader
McConnell wants a trial with no existing
evidence and no new evidence a trial
without evidence is not a trial it's a
cover-up the White House argues that the
request for more evidence proves the
Democrats don't have a strong case
against the president they said in their
brief we have overwhelming evidence and
they're afraid to make their case think
about it think about it it's common
sense overwhelming evidence to impeach
the President of the United States and
then they come here on the first day and
they say you know what we need some more
evidence the White House also argues
that the documents and witnesses are
privileged in order to shape foreign
policy the president must be able to
have private deliberations with advisers
and that's an argument rejected by the
Democrats make the argument that the
president's conduct here was was it was
conduct that every president should be
allowed to engage in and I think that
most Americans don't believe that for
that mr. Chief Justice I yield back the
Democrats failed to pass their
amendments under McConnell's rules
though there will be another chance to
debate the need for more witnesses and
documents but only after opening
arguments and the cross-examination of
the house managers and White House
lawyers he just watch Donald Trump was
reported to be monitoring proceedings
while attending the World Economic Forum
in Switzerland
position remains unchanged Democrats now
have three days beginning on Wednesday
to make their opening arguments the
White House says its lawyers may not
need that much time and certainly hopes
that all of this will be wrapped up
before the State of the Union address on
February the 4th with Donald Trump's
acquittal Hsieh Burton C al Jazeera
Washington